hi YouTube my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw Cody's out a
lot in October which is good because he
doesn't love jump scares and listen I've
been seeing some scary movies
today being a great example of that on
my Twitter I asked if I should watch the
new My Little Pony movie or happy
deathday and a lot of people rightfully
so tweeted at me that it's October
I should see the scary movie choice
obviously so I did and I went with My
Little Pony I have never seen an episode
of My Little Pony before but I have seen
the brony documentary and I played with
My Little Pony dolls growing up I loved
them my father owned a model trains shop
and he would go in every Saturday and I
would go in with him and help him run
the shop but really I would just sit
under his desk
playing with My Little Ponies and I
loved their hair and I loved their icons
and I loved to them I super understand
the craze behind it I think I I mean
they're beautiful they're all about
friendship and togetherness I don't know
what there is to not enjoy about My
Little Ponies
everyone was so shocked when the brony
thing came out it's like guys like this
so creepy I don't know I mean I guess
maybe there's creepy elements to it I
don't really know I think it's cool I
like what you're gonna like man like
that's awesome but I had never seen
anything for my little pony and I I'm
gonna be very honest was like maybe
it'll be like interesting and engaging
for the episode if I don't like it like
people would be so I don't know I liked
it I thought it was good I will say it
felt more like a very long episode of a
TV show than a movie but it was fun and
the morals of friendship were there and
they had a couple really cool characters
and their beautiful ponies with
excellent hair so the animation is
something that was a bit sloppy to me
it's definitely not gonna win any awards
if it wasn't at all like watching you
know a Pixar movie or or even some of
the ones that Cody and I have seen
earlier this year
it was a little sloppy but the stories
and the songs were so fun and just like
silly fun
it wasn't taking itself too seriously
which think the Lord above but it was
just it was just a silly goofy fun time
like I said I really don't think this
movie is gonna win any awards but it was
really cute there was a mom and daughter
behind me and the daughter was like
talking throughout the whole thing which
was fine it was only me and then those
other two people and she was talking out
through the whole thing but like with
excitement and like oh my god it's that
I don't know where neither name I would
you know the rainbow one okay like just
very excited and the story is about
princess Twilight Sparkle purple unicorn
who is putting on this festival for SIA
SIA the horse that's her name right yeah
yeah see ya then there's this bad evil
horse who comes in she's serving this
bad evil monster magic guy and it's all
about finding help and through
friendship and through Pony powers I
didn't know anything about the
characters I knew that Tara Strong had
voiced them in the past I remember from
the bro me documentary that the Apple
like the the farm horse was the one who
kind of put that together if I remember
incorrectly but they were really easy to
get to know and identify with and I know
everyone is sitting on the edge of their
seats to see who I identify with the
most right everyone right okay I think
it's Pinkie Pie she was so excited all
the time when I really identified with
that the rainbow one Rainbow Dash and
the Apple one apple cider
I wrote down their names that I thought
they were what did I write Applejack and
Rainbow puffer definitely gave each
other there is a lot of gay themes in
this which is cute I don't know if
that's intentional but it's just it's
really fun to see
friends being celebrated and anytime
anything is really buddy-buddy and
really friendship based it feels gay
because it's not often that that's
really portrayed it opens up with the
princesses of Equestria I think it's
called and their hair is just beautiful
and flowy well two of them there's
there's three princesses four I guess
there's four princesses and two of their
hair is there it's just beautiful and
then two of them are just normal luck of
the draw I guess then the first song is
we got this and they're all putting
together this festival and it's really
cute and it's catchy and silly and it
feels kind of like I've never seen the
lego movie but it feels kind of like
everything is awesome like it's just
like a silly song but it's fun and it's
well done and super cute yes we got this
then see a horse comes out and it's a
little weird because she's kind of like
too serious and she's like prancing out
and she has this hair she's not voice
actress and I mean she's a voice vocal
you know savant-like wonderful great
work but a little weird to see her
coming out of a horse there's just kind
of weird so they're preparing for this
festival and the bad guys show up and
they freeze the three other princesses
except for the purple Twilight Sparkle
princess and who is great as well I love
her purple and oh I was gonna wear my
unicorn horn there we go
perfect she's the only one who makes it
out and so with the help of her friends
they go to try to find the Eagle horses
they stumble across this city that was
definitely inspired a bit by Disney's
Treasure Planet
I think it's Disney I love that film
there's flying ships and the whole town
is very like steampunky it's really cool
something that I wasn't expecting and a
My Little Pony movie it was it was
really good and then they're introduced
to this suave orange cat
blue hair is literal it's I quit blue
hair it's he's skulking in the corner
the more I watched it it was more like
Malcolm actually because he's just so
smooth such a smooth jock you're such a
cool cat see what I did there he was
like the typical bear the story is very
predictable that's why I say it feels
more like a TV show versus a movie it's
not bad it's just predictable so the cat
is like his smooth-talker self and he at
first is gonna sell them out and then
they help him he's like oh shoot
shouldn't have done that so he makes a
nice character arc then they make
friends with this group of parents who
are pirates and the pirate parrot and
queen is so cool like I can't believe
this is about to come out of my mouth
but I want to cosplay as the pirate
parrot Queen from the My Little Pony
movie and then again the pirate parrots
have this song and it's really great
it's time to be awesome
then there's mermaid horses which
wouldn't that just be a sea horse you
find out the evil horses motivations and
it's that she lost her horn she was a
unicorn she lost her horn as a child in
a bear attack you know we've heard that
story a thousand times
it's kind of weird motivation she she
lost her horn in a bear attack and then
her friends wouldn't hang out there
anymore I feel like they could have
maybe made that better than the carrot
the carrots the parrots come back to
kick some booty they could have made
that better as well
mermaid Eagle comes back and then the
cat comes back and they're all gonna go
save Equestria and they do and it's cute
it's really cute see a pony was the
worst part for me she was a little on
the voice acting was really cool though
I actually don't know who was eaten this
was Tara Strong in this Emily Blunt I
knew she was the bad pony I knew I
recognized her poise Kristin Chenoweth
Oh Tara Strong
oh it's Twilight spurt 90% of people
like this movie and Rotten Tomatoes only
55% weird when 90% of people like
something and then the critics are like
mmm not for me no thank you
well I I have to say I enjoyed this I
think maybe it would have been funnier
if I was like upset about it the whole
time but I'm not gonna lie I liked it
next week doesn't seem to have very many
movies coming out we've got Geo storm
the Snowman boo - Ahmadiyya ho I'm not
quite sure what I'll see yet I may go
back and visit happy deathday or the
foreigner foreigner what do you guys
think that I should watch hopefully Cody
will view with me next week and thanks
so much for for watching my opinions my
little pony I will see you all very soon
My Little Pony My Little Pony My Little
Pony My Little Pony you always be in my
pony my little pony
always be in my heart that's my
childhood
[Music]